a lack of
water and extreme heat is holding the
western united states
hostage wildfires started early this
season
here in oregon the so-called bootleg
fire has already destroyed an area
bigger than los angeles
the mega fire is burning so hard and
generating so much
energy that it is essentially creating
its own weather
spreading smoke as far as new york city
the fire is moving so fast that many
ranchers weren't able to rescue their
cattle
more than a hundred families have
already lost their homes to the flames
while thousands were evacuated
it's totally unclear how long it will
take firefighters to get the flames
under control many roads are still
closed
the national guard has been deployed to
control traffic
with only ranchers allowed in to check
on their cattle
in many areas
the little community of sprague river is
only miles away from the edge of the
fire
summer has been living here for more
than 20 years
i know that there were there's probably
hundreds of cattle that have been lost
and there's probably hundreds of cattle
that are still out there
the jane's lost a bunch the yamsey ranch
up
joe jane they lost some the gallagher's
out here at whiskey creek ranch
which are like my family the fire
department
put out information signs in the whole
area to keep people
updated brendan and his wife just moved
here to start a life
as farmers this fire has been much
bigger
and seeing the clouds from it and just
seeing the containment line only be
about this big right here
for days and days and days it's it's
been a big one
but when the wind blows that hard and
the fire is that big it's kind of
hard to stop especially with this dry
but i know that they're
rationing ground water all around here
too
farmers that are newer to farming
it's on a first come first serve as far
as how long you've had your well
and how long you've been using it
year to year it is becoming clearer
access to water is defining who will be
able to survive in this area
and who won't make it
and it is already a reality that there
is not enough water
to meet the demands
scott soyuz is a father of three and a
third generation farmer within the
klamath basin
a huge man-made irrigation system
we don't want to see bloom in the
alfalfa like this this is a crop that's
under stress
and and it's under stress because we
can't get enough water to it we're
trying to take a very limited
ground water resource and we're trying
to spread it over a lot of acres to try
to keep our perennial crops alive
scott's 400 acre farm is at an elevation
of four thousand
feet besides alfalfa he's growing onions
peppermint garlic and horseradish
i'm not willing to stand aside and and
roll over for this
i'm willing to fight for it because it's
disrespectful to my dad and it's
disrespectful to my grandfather
and it's it's honestly not right for me
not to give my children the
opportunity to to to raise their family
here and to have their kids have the
opportunity to farm
that's my responsibility and that's why
i don't walk away from it
bendival has a much smaller farm but
shares the same problems
looking at something like climate change
it's very concerning because what does
that mean for the sustainability
of what we're doing here into the future
and at the same time i think that
irrigated ag
is a great way for us to be able to
be insulated somewhat from climate
change because we're not dependent
on on rainfall in a particular month you
know we can average that out at least
over a year or maybe over several
years if you have enough storage
capacity in reservoirs
and it gives us an opportunity to be
able to produce crops even
when we are seeing more extremes in
climate
ben wants his daughters to continue the
family tradition
he lost the leg in a car accident but
that hasn't stopped him from
fighting for his family's right to farm
the fight for water has already
mobilized some farmers who set up a
full-time protest next to the channels
that regulate how much water they are
allowed
to access we're just here trying to
educate people trying to get them to
stand up and
take their water i mean it's our water
and we either got to take it and
stand up and get it or we're gonna lose
it we're gonna have to forcefully take
it and we're gonna have to get
the sheriff or somebody's gonna have to
come help us and we're gonna have to
take it and
get it flowing or we're not gonna have
water here this is the very place where
officials decide
how to divide the water do they divert
it to farmers for their crops
or do they keep it in the lakes and
rivers on native lands
with too little water and the extreme
heat fish species which are central to
the diet and culture of local native
tribes
are endangered all this biomass
that we see here and by the fall
all this will have decomposed
and resulted in the death of all the
young of the year
fish alex gagna
is a biologist who is monitoring the
quality of the water
and the status of the fish population
for the klamath tribes
in the short term there's not much we
can do about climate change
however we can alter the water quality
in a positive way that means fencing
cattle off of streams
not adding any additional phosphorus to
the system
and allowing the aquaticus ecosystem to
heal itself
begin healing itself nature is amazing
at doing that
but first we need to remove the human
pressure from the system
the things that the native american
tribe the klamath tribes
here value have been largely completely
disregarded
during the the settlement process and it
continues to be
almost completely disregarded in terms
of
striking a balance between the ecosystem
the values of the tribes agriculture
and the treatment of the landscape in
general it's been extremely one-sided
don gentry is the chairman of the
klamath tribes
they have been living in this area for
thousands of years
when you look out in the distance and
you see the cascades and
how beautiful it looks and then you look
into the green
water that looks like pea soup this time
of year knowing that that's
great conditions that are lethal to our
fish it's it's heartbreaking
we're people of the lakes marshes and
streams everything that the creator
placed here
uh in the rivers and in the marshes and
the lakes and on the landscape
was here and provided subsistence for us
all those resources uh
uh even in our legends and stories and
remind us of uh how we're to be and what
we're not to do how we're to live
you know remind us that creator placed
these things here for us for our
subsistence
but to never abuse that you know we take
only what we need
and use everything that we take we're
stewards you know and we're a part of
things definitely concerned about
violence and and you know just the
continued uh
racist-based marginalization of who we
are
and you know what those fish mean to us
we're
portrayed as not being as important as
other folks that generate a lot of money
through agriculture
there hardly seem to be any possible
winners in this
war over water but there will be many
losers if the climate crisis isn't
stopped
charlotte sirs whose father could swim
in this lake
might be one of them
you